- So, don't you also have Jay
Leno on "Last Man Standing"
speaking to cars.
- The best treat.
The best treat ever imaginable
is how fresh that guy,
from doing all he does,
he listens and he's,
don't tell him this.
He's a good actor.
And he's getting better.
He's a gentle, wonderful, listening actor.
And I said, it's,
I don't know where the
skillset came from, don't care.
He's added so much to the show.
It's, you know, it's great.
- Oh my God, well, I love him so much.
And so I have his number
and so I thought we
would just call him up,
because you both like cars.
So control room,
can we see if we can get
Jay on the line real quick?
- Hi, you guys?
- What's up Jay?
I'm here with Tim Allen.
Where are you?
- I'm in the California desert.
I'm in a 1959 tank.
It's a ferret scout car.
It's got a 30 caliber machine gun on it
and, I'm just driving around.
I, see this is the
difference between Tim and I
See right now I'm in a tank,
and it's got a machine gun.
I know Tim is gonna be
testing new moisturizers
with you in a few minutes.
So that's sort of difference
(laughter)
- I mean, I love that it's
just a day that ends in wine
and you're just hanging out in a tank.
That's amazing.
- A ferret tank with a 30 caliber.
Where's my life, I'm trapped in my garage.
But I get to be on with Kelly,
so forget about that, Jay,
but how are you buddy?
- I'm good.
I'm saying I was just,
I always tell Tim this.
You know, when I did "The Tonight Show,"
a couple of times a day.
"Oh, hi, Jay Leno, how are you?"
Since I've been on Tim's show,
I get stopped all the
time now, it's hilarious.
It's amazing how many
people watch our program.
- [Kelly] 'Cause it's awesome.
- I'm taping an episode
with Tim this week.
You know, he's very modest.
You know, Tim said some
nice things about me
and I'll say some nice things about him.
You know, Tim is such a regular guy,
people don't realize how big a star he is.
I mean, at one point he
had the number one book,
the number one movie and
the number one TV show
all at the same time,
which never ever happens.
But, because he's a regular guy
and pays, plays a regular guy (mumbles)
"Oh, there's Tim, hi, how you doing?"
You know, I don't think he
realizes how big a star he is.
But, with the film.
I mean, "Galaxy Quest" is
one of my all time fave.
I go to "The Godfather" and
then I go "Galaxy Quest"
'cause it's such a funny,
gentle kind movie about aliens.
- I love "Galaxy Quest"
- and I never seen
that done before.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- Thank you, Jay.
- No, I'm a huge fan of it.
I'm actually a huge fan of both of you.
So I'm the one honored sitting here but,
I have to ask you though,
'cause once again, I'm super competitive.
Earlier we were talking
about Tim's racing days, Jay.
So, who would win?
We've been next to each other
in cars as well, old cars.
So who would win between you and Tim?
- Well, let's just say,
old age and treasury
beats youth and ambition
any day of the week.
(laughter)
- That was nicely said.
(mumbling)
- [Tim] I'll tell you this, every--
- I'm not a racer.
I enjoy cars and I like 'em.
You know, it's like,
I like to make love
but I don't wanna be a gynecologist,
you know what I'm saying?
So it's the same kinda thing.
(laughter)
You know I,
I like cars, I like to work on 'em.
But Tim's a racer.
Tim actually does
professional racing, I don't.
I just go off.
- I love how you just got
gynecologist in there.
That was the best part of my day,
I'm gonna be honest with you.
- There you go.
- Oh my God.
I love you guys so much.
Thanks for picking up my call, Jay.
That was super nice.
You've gotta come by soon, I love you.
- There aren't that many
- [Tim] Thank you, Jay.
Tanks that have Bluetooth,
so this is cool.
(laughter)
- All right, everybody--
- I'm, I'll see you
at the show this week.
- [Kelly] Yeah.